Hey guys
i'm so excited to be back and finish
justice league with zach snyder the
zack snyder cut
i can't tell you how excited i am
dah! But there's a lot of work that needs
to be done
obviously even though i already did a
lot of work so
right now i'm in the middle of finishing
an
action bit with the new justice league
theme
and i want to preview a little bit of
that so let me
play you a little bit of that thing in
action mode
that was a little sneak peek of
that theme i hope you like that and
i'm very much looking forward to see you
guys soon
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new justice league
snyder cut video junkiexl dropped a new
clip
of his version of the music the
soundtrack with the snyder cut trailer
so we'll break it down
the flash movie people also revealed new
information about the movie that they're
going
to be rebooting the dceu so i'll explain
what that means too
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the new version
of the dceu going forward after the
flash movie
so we'll start with the justice league
snyder cuts stuff first then i'll talk
about the flash movie in the flashpoint
reboot of the dceu
so starting with number five in this
clip junkiexl references working on the
new music again
quote unquote because he had already
completed a lot of it a few years ago
it sounds totally badass as you would
expect if you're a fan of his work on
batman v superman or the other work that
he's done on other movies it's going to
sound really badass on the snyder cut
but what he's talking about is that back
in 2017 before zack snyder was forced to
leave the movie
he had planned to have junkiexl do the
music just like he done the music for
batman v superman so that the two movies
would feel and sound very similar
because they're meant to be connected
albeit adding a lot of theme songs from
the other justice league members
like he had to incorporate the theme
songs from the other justicing members
like aquaman the flash cyborg in
addition to the stuff that he'd already
done for superman batman and wonder
woman
and if we're talking about unite the
seven you also have the green lantern
stuff that they had referenced too that
they were planning on doing during the
movie that we'll see play out during the
snyder cut
but you all probably remember that when
zack snyder left the movie the studio
and i believe joss whedon decided they
totally wanted to go in a different
direction with the composer and totally
different take on the music so they
fired junkiexl
and hired danny elfman to come do the
theatrical cut he's the one behind the
iconic batman 1989 theme music and
batman returns he's done a bunch of
other stuff
many other movies over many many years
so you're probably familiar with most of
his work
they even reused some of the musical
cues from his batman 1989 theme song
during the theatrical cut if you listen
carefully it's in this meeting scene
between gordon and the justice league i
believe they released it online before
the movie came out
it's when batman shows up they plays for
just a couple seconds
but at that time when they fired junkiexl he'd already completed a lot of work
on his version of the music so number
four when the justice league snyder cut
was greenlit of course zack snyder
brought him back on to finish his
version of the music
the big difference though in between
what he was doing before and what he's
doing now for the snyder cut
is that back when zack snyder was still
doing the theatrical cut
he said that the studio had forced him
to keep the total run time of the movie
down to two hours
so the new soundtrack the junkiexl is
working on
for the snyder cut is four hours long so
that's twice
as much music than he was making for the
original theatrical cut
it's not quite as crazy as it sounds
because they reuse a lot of musical cues
during different scenes and they wind up
reusing a lot of the bigger theme songs
from previous movies like henry cavill's
man of steel
theme music or wonder woman's theme song
that they've already done for a previous
movie
the version of the snyder cut scene that
he dropped in that clip
says he's taken from one of the major
fight scenes and based on the way the
music muse through the piece it becomes
really hopeful towards the end
like hardcore but hopeful because it is
junky xl
it sounds like it's just happening from
one of the major steppenwolf battles
either the cooling tower fight scene
earlier in the movie or the big final
battle at the end of the movie
like number three here's a version of
the theatrical cut with this big fight
scene obviously this is going to be very
different in the snyder cup but there's
a version of this
during the snyder cut here's that same
clip with the junkiexl music again and
see how much better this sounds than the
theatrical cut
isn't that totally awesome i can't wait
to hear the rest of his soundtrack
they'll probably release some of that
before they actually release the snyder
cut on hbo max there'll be a bunch more
previews and trailers and clips for the
rest of this year and early next year
too
but number two moving into the flash
flashpoint movie reboot panel
from this past weekend at dc fandom if
you didn't realize there was also a
second day of dc fandom with a bunch
more movie stuff and a bunch of the
other tv stuff they didn't have time for
during the previous dc fandom day but
the flash movie producers were talking
about rebooting the dceu
during the flash movie which is
obviously really big news it kind of got
buried in the weekend
they said through the time travel
changes in the flashpoint of it all the
movie itself will change
everything we know about the dc universe
but that the new timeline won't
completely forget
everything that came before and
everyone's like what the hell does that
mean are they reconning everything
what's going on
so the producers did clarify that even
though they're changing a lot of things
about the dc movies going forward
with flashpoint they're not going to
completely retcon everything like the
events of man of steel batman v superman
justice league the wonder woman movies
the aquaman movie and then never
reference it again
but it definitely sounds like they're
using the flashpoint twist to creatively
retune things a little bit and
incorporate
other new characters for future dc
movies going forward
and fix any of the major issues that
they have like explaining why ben
affleck's batman
isn't going to show up in the next
justice league movie and incorporate
some of the shazam and black adam
characters the justice society in a
bigger way
because those franchises will also be
changing the landscape of the connected
dc movies
so number one wtf the rock and the
producers in the black adam movie also
said that they're using the black adam
movie to do a lot of that same work too
completely change what the dc connected
movies look like
before justice league happened nobody in
the universe had ever mentioned the
shazam characters and now they're
suddenly a huge deal they're all super
powerful
like the rock was hyping up black adam
versus the justice league during a
different movie
while he was dropping the black adam
teaser this is the clip of him talking
about that he calls
all them on puts them on notice i need
you guys to help me get a message out to
uh
to some of the other ones some of the
other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam
aquaman wonder woman
batman and superman
let's let them know something things
will never be the same
because the hierarchy of power in the dc
universe
is about to change
it just sounds like the flash movie will
try to fix all that continuity so that
it all makes sense when black adam for
instance starts showing up with other
justice league characters
but also on the other side of that from
what they're saying if you're still
wondering about people like ben affleck
and his version of batman they're saying
they're not totally getting rid of him
but the movie will explain suddenly why
it's michael keaton's batman showing up
all over the place from his universe let
me know in the comments though if they
are really using the flash movie to
alter the continuity
of the dceu what do you want them to
include in the new version of the
timeline with all these connected movies
going forward
i'll do more videos as they drop more
justice league snyder cut clips and
trailers so no worries there'll be a
bunch more of that stuff happening this
year
if you haven't seen it too the boys on
amazon is also a really great
dark justice league parody and i've been
doing videos for that
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
but click here for the new batman
trailer and all those easter eggs and
click here for the boys season 2 episode
4 video with a whole bunch of really
dark justice league easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!